hi mystery recap here today i'm going to
explain the american drama thriller film
called before i wake
spoilers ahead watch out and take care
[Music]
it is midnight when a grown man slowly
enters a little kid's room
he points a gun at the sleeping child he
seems to be nervous and apologizes to
him calling him cody
a sudden commotion makes him pull the
trigger the gunfire awakens cody
the man breaks down in tears and
apologizes to him
cut to a few months later a couple named
jesse and mark hobson have been approved
as foster parents
they sit across natalie a worker at the
foster care
she tells them about an eight-year-old
boy named cody cody's father was never
around and his mother died when he was
only three cody has not had many good
experiences in the foster care system
his former foster parents had abandoned
him leaving him to live alone for about
a month before he was rescued
he has sleep issues but he is resilient
and smart
natalie thinks he would be perfect for
the hobsons to foster
having found the perfect kid for them
the hobsons returned home happily that
day
their young son sean had died by
accidentally drowning in a bathtub
this had a huge impact on the couple but
now they are ready to welcome a new
member to their family
at home they redecorate the house to
make it fit for cody
mark takes down every picture of sean
from the walls and only leaves their
family picture
he also sets an extra handle on the wall
beside the bathtub
later that day jessie tells her
self-help group about their decision to
foster cody
everyone there is happy for her jessie
has had trouble sleeping since shawn's
death
the next day the couple impatiently
waits for cody to arrive
natalie's car parks in their driveway
and they rush to see cody
he wishes the couple a good morning he
brings with him a box
that mark helps him carry inside as cody
is looking around the house
the family picture with sean seems to
have caught his eyes
he stares at it as mark tells him about
his collection of games
the adults then take him to his new room
which he loves
especially the curtains with butterflies
on them natalie tells them that cody
likes to collect butterflies as a hobby
later that night the couple talk cody to
bed but after they leave
cody sits up and opens the box that he
brought with him
inside is a kind of soda and a book
about butterflies he sips on the soda
and starts reading the book under the
blanket using a torchlight
he doesn't sleep at all the following
day is his first day at school
that day at school cody meets annie and
befriends her
jessie is folding cody's laundry that
day when she finds his secret box inside
is his book about butterflies
several cans of soda and a bottle of
stimulants
when she tucks him to bed at night she
asks him about the box
according to him the stimulants and cans
of soda are to help him not fall asleep
he adds that when he falls asleep the
canker man comes
thinking that the child just has
nightmares jesse dismisses it
she tells him that the man will go away
with little reasoning
however cody believes that the canker
man ate his mother and is always with
him
jesse puts him to bed and goes to mark
in their living room
she feels sorry for going through cody's
box she feels like she has invaded his
privacy
but mark assures her it is for his own
good sometime later
they are watching a movie together then
all of a sudden several butterflies fly
into the room
they look holographic the couple is
beyond surprised to see this many at
once
mark captures one in a jar for cody
while jesse closes the windows
as the windows close all of the
butterflies disappear
the couple is left stunned jessie has a
hard time falling asleep that night
she goes down to the kitchen where she
hears an odd noise she looks around to
see if there is an intruder
suddenly sean appears in the dark living
room
jessie is in shock a glass falls from
her hand and breaks
when she looks up again sean is gone she
goes to cody's room to check on him
he sleeps peacefully cut to the next day
jesse is back with a self-help group
she tells them about seeing sean
according to her
sean seems angry to be replaced by cody
later that day
mark notices cody staring at their
family picture with sean in it
he talks to the couple about sean they
lovingly answer all cody's questions
at night the butterflies appear again
they look around when suddenly
shawn appears in the room he is wearing
the same clothes as their family picture
the couple is beyond surprised they walk
up to him to touch him
when they do they realize that he is
actually real but sean suddenly
disappears
at the same time we see cody wake up he
comes down and apologizes to the couple
the breakfast the following day is
awkward jesse and mark do not know what
to
say they are still in shock but they
believe that shawn's appearance has
something to do with cody
cody apologizes to them for something
later
when cody is back from school the family
watches videos of sean
it is a christmas video and all three of
them look very happy in it
that night after cody falls asleep mark
and jesse stay in the living room
suddenly the room lights up with
christmas lights and a christmas tree
appears too
just then sean appears wearing the
clothes he did in the video
the video has come to life mark and
jesse are left speechless
they finally realize that cody is
blessed with supernatural power
all of his dreams come to life while he
sleeps however
when he wakes up the dream vanishes cut
to the next day
cody draws a figure of a man and
proceeds to scribble over it
he tells annie that it is the canker man
sometimes when cody scribbles over him
it keeps the man away jesse puts the
pictures of sean back for cody
to see she wants to meet her dead son
again
however mark is not fond of the idea he
accuses jesse of using cody to fulfill
her desires
but jesse insists that cody is the only
one who can help them heal
irritated mark puts the photo frames
away
the next day cody brings a butterfly
trapped in a jar to school
but his bully tate breaks it cody has
been staying up all night in fear of the
canker man
so he almost falls asleep in the class
during the lunch break he gets
permission to rest in the class for a
while
he is alone there when he falls asleep
cody dreams of the canker man
cody's blessing is also a curse along
with his dreams
his nightmares are real too as cody
sleeps his bully enters the classroom
and faces the canker man
and he sees the canker man indulge tape
and yells in here
cody wakes up but tate has disappeared
the police arrive at the school to
investigate the disappearance
cody cannot risk sleeping now so he
takes coffee to avoid sleeping
that night cody reads the book about
butterflies like he usually does
suddenly he hears a noise he checks
under the bed when suddenly
tate's ghost appears in front of him and
drags him under the bed
cody tries to fight and screams i am
awake meanwhile
sean appears before jesse he too is
saying i am awake
cody yells loudly which makes the dreams
go away jesse rushes to him
asks him what is wrong and tries to calm
him down
the following day jesse talks to a
doctor about cody's insomnia
meanwhile cody and mark go shopping and
buy stuff for cody's room
when they get back home two police
officers are in front of their house
they want to interview cody about tate's
disappearance
later that day cody asks the couple
about shawn's death
but the couple dismisses the questions
jessie mixes the prescribed sleeping
pills with cody's milk
unbeknownst to her husband and he drinks
it
marx informs cody that sean had died
from drowning as he tucks him to bed
the drug makes cody sleep peacefully
that night jesse and mark are in the
living room again
some time later sean appears in front of
them but he looks evil and vomits water
mark rushes up to wake cody but he
cannot wake up because of the drug
soon the dream turns into a nightmare a
tall creature appears in front of jesse
in the living room
she runs to cody's room and locks the
door mark is worried about cody not
waking
up just then jesse confesses to have
drugged him
she watches in horror as the creature
devours mark
suddenly she falls unconscious she wakes
up in the morning to cody calling 9-1-1
mark is nowhere to be found it is as if
he has disappeared into thin air
the police arrive at the scene and
accuse jesse of drugging the kid
they believe that jesse and mark are
abusing cody so they take him away
as jesse cries for them to stop jessie
then goes to natalie
but she too accuses her of child abuse
and tells her to go away
however jessie notices cody's file on
her desk and manages to steal it
through the file she finds out about a
man named wheel and young
he is the father of the second family
code he was fostered by
she goes to see him young tells her that
he and his wife fostered cody for 15
months before his dream swallowed his
wife to
he was so angry at cody that he almost
killed him this is the scene we saw at
the beginning of the film
he then asks her to kill cody so that no
others can be victims of his nightmares
but jesse refuses from the file she also
finds cody's mother's information and
her hospital reports
she decides to go to the hospital and
investigate further
the hospital provides her with her
mother's belongings it consists of a
pillow shape like a butterfly in her
journal
reading the journal in the reports
jessie finds the secret about the canker
man's existence
she then goes to the orphanage cody is
staying at with the pillow
cody hasn't slept for several nights so
his caretakers are worried about him
unknown about the canker man they give
him a tranquilizer to help him sleep
cody dreams of the man that night as
well when jesse walks into the building
she sees several nightmares in every
room first
she is startled by a flutter of black
moths then she sees shawn drowning in
the bathtub
next she sees a horrifying looking woman
twist cody's head
lastly she sees mark appears in front of
her scared
she closes the door to that room she
finally reaches cody's room
the canker man runs towards her to
attack her but instead of running away
she shows him the butterfly pillow the
canker man stops when he sees it
jesse slowly hugs the man as she does
that the man turns into cody who then
disappears
jesse picks a sleeping cody up and takes
him outside
natalie has been indulged by the canker
man and comes back to life
she sees jessie take him away but lets
her they see several beautiful
butterflies flying in the hallway
his nightmare has changed into a magical
dream
cut to the next day jesse tells cody
that his mother's name was andrea and
that she died of pancreatic cancer
andrea had found out about cody's gift
when he was little
she has written it in her journal but
when cody was just three
andrea was diagnosed with cancer cody
had seen his mother on the verge of
death
battling cancer she was thin and bald at
that time
since he was too young to recognize her
as his mother his little mind made up
that it was the canker man
he was told that cancer had taken his
mother away with time
he made up the canker man so he believed
that he took her away
this began his nightmares now that cody
knows that the canker man is not
real jesse believes that his nightmare
will not come back
however mark and other people that the
canker man had taken still haven't come
back
jesse believes that as cody learns to
control his power there might be a
possibility of them coming back
cody thanks jesse for bringing him home
and calls her mom
he begins to learn how to control his
magical gift
subscribe for more videos like this turn
on notifications
and leave a like to help the channel out
thank you for watching